so let's bring in fox news medical
contributor dr mark
siegel dr siegel thank you for being
here let's start with that
um that even people who receive this
vaccine could be criminally charged does
all any of this rise to the level of
criminality in your mind i'm deeply
disturbed about this alicia thanks for
having me on i i mean not from the
patient side because
you know one one poor young woman told
fox news that
she'd been charged 150 she has young
children she's working
i mean it's hard to think that she had
intent and intent would have to be you
know
trying to do something fraudulent but
certainly there's enough information out
there
to what brian eunice just said that it's
got to be health
frontline health care workers uh and and
the elderly people in nursing homes are
front of the line
so you know if somebody did this
deliberately
in terms of the patient side i could see
them being charged but the real issue
here is that clearly
in my mind park here knew what they were
doing i mean they advertised this as
anyone with a pre-existing condition
anyone that's an elderly person
anyone you know high risk well that's
not where we are yet with this vaccine
and this is deeply disturbing
i'm just curious what happens to the
folks who did receive the vaccine but
won't receive the second
because of all of this is do they have
to get back in line is there anything
wrong with this in terms of their health
alicia that is a really excellent
question now if i were the health
commissioner and howard zucker is very
very concerned about this new york state
health commissioner i still think
that the state has an obligation now to
give the second shot because you don't
want to waste the first one
because i think the immunity uh for the
pfizer shot it's about 53
on the first shot but that probably
wears off so i think that you you
pretty much have to give the second shot
now that's what i would recommend
despite the the shady circumstances okay
well let okay let's move on let's
discuss this
another vaccine maker novavax it has
announced it will begin a phase three
trial
it also is a two shot regimen but it
doesn't need to be kept as cold as the
others what can you tell us about this
well i'm really happy about this this
vaccine i've been following for a long
time and this is
going to be this sanofi makes a very
similar one so we're going to end up
with
six potentially six vaccines you have
the moderna and the pfizer that we've
been talking about
the messenger rna johnson and johnson
and the
oxford astrozenica shots both use what's
called
a adenovirus platform where a virus
delivers the
protein payload and now these let me
tell you about this novovax
it actually grows a protein in insect
cells
that's a lot like the protein of the
virus then you deliver it into the body
with a chemical
and you end up with a robust immune
response in clinical trials so far the
immunity is huge on this
and it's very similar to a vaccine we
already have on the market
which is the shingles vaccine it uses a
very similar
technology i have a lot of hope that
this might emerge too which
brings to the point that by the spring
when we start to vaccinate the whole
general population
we might end up with several choices and
this one does not have to be kept cold
as you said
oh that sounds very encouraging on the
vaccination effort underway today as you
know dr fauci said that the united
states will
not meet the goal of having 20 million
americans
vaccinated by the end of the year here's
dr fauci
we certainly are not at the numbers that
we wanted to be
at the end of december you heard talking
about
40 million doses for 20 million people i
mean even if you undercount
2 million as an undercount how much
under count could it be so we are below
where we want to be dr siegel in your
opinion what went wrong here
well you know one thing that i like i
like to be a glass half full person
first of all i like the idea that four
star general
gus perna took responsibility for this
the military had a lot to do with the
deployment
and so he's saying it's his fault that
he over-promised but i want to tell you
the other good
part of this alisa consider that we went
from vaccinating in clinical trials
thousands of people and now we're
vaccinating millions so you know what
even if we've they've only distributed
11 million doses so far and we wanted 40
million out by now
i know we're in a race to get everybody
vaccinated but we're also
watching everyone very carefully for
side effects when i got the vaccine i
did really well i got a bit of a
headache
a little bit of a fatigue some soreness
in my arm it was terrific
but i want to watch all millions out
there that are getting it to make sure
that it's as well tolerated as we think
it is and so far so good
so the rush to vaccinate is one thing
but you don't want to go
past keeping a careful eye on people who
are getting it
okay dr mark siegel thank you so much we
appreciate your time today
great that we have the vaccine thanks
alicia thank you thank you